What does this have to do with images?
Well, let me tell you.
I'm going to introduce this using the
notion of face images 'because frankly
it was this eigenvector approach to
doing face recognition that really,
I think, got people's attention.
Think of an image now,
not as a two dimensional thing, but
as just one great big long vector.
Okay?
So it's just got a whole
bunch of values in it.
So for example, suppose I had
a vector that was 100 by 100 long.
How many pixels is that, Megan?
100 by 100.
>> 10,000.
You got it right.
100 times 100 is 10,000.
So, that's just a 10,000 long vector.
If I don't worry about the fact that
they're pixels located in a particular
position, which, by the way, is going to
be an interesting problem later,
if I just think of them as values,
that's a 10,000 dimensional space.
Right.
There's 10,000 dimensions,
each dimension has a value.
What's the value?
It's the value of the pixel that
corresponds to that location.
This location is another pixel.
It's value 18, fine,
that's it's value here.
So the idea is that an image is
just a 10,000 dimensional vector.
Question.
How many of those 10,000
dimensional vectors,
how many 100 by 100 pictures,
are actually pictures of faces?
I mean, just of a face?
Answer.
Not a whole lot, okay?
In fact, most values, all right,
if I just randomly put numbers in tho,
that vector.
Right.
I get out,
you know random pixels everywhere.
Right?
The idea is, that,
faces are a very special set of vectors.
They're not all possible vectors, and
they're not distributed
everywhere in this image space.
They are on some particular,
what's referred to as a subspace,
sometimes a manifold, okay.
They're in a subspace of all images.
Okay?
By the way,
we sometimes call that subspace,
face space.
What's face space?
Is the subspace in the space of images
that are the pictures of faces.
All right.
So here's what we want to do.
We and this is color coded so
we want to build a low dimensional,
because we're going to try to get a nice
dimensionality reduction going on here,
linear, we'll talk about the use of
linearity to be able to just do dot
products together coefficient, subspace,
so it's going to be some reduced space,
that explains most of
the variation seen in face images.
And that's just drawn out here,
this looks just like what we had before.
Where we had blue dots and,
and orange dots.
Now I'm telling you well actually,
even though this is drawn as
just a two dimensional space,
'because I can only draw two,
it's a 10,000 dimensional space.
10,000.
You like that.
Okay, fine.
10,000 pixels and
the idea is let me find the direction or
directions in that image along
which most of the face images lie.
And that's what it shows here,
that the cyan color is sort of, ideas
that the face images are there, and
then we've got all these other
images that are not images of faces.
They're cats, well they're all sorts of
things, okay, whatever the internet has
pictures of and
all other possible things, all right.